if you're looking for ways to just start
create something you're proud of and not
limit yourself then this video is for
you
well in the beginning I was just making
music for fun it was your hobby and I
actually started studying business and
finance and government I want to make
something that I'm proud of
I don't really classify my own track
stuff like because I doubt it
I kind of like just look at it as music
I don't want to like to put myself into
one genre need motivation watch a top 10
with believe nation what's up it's Evan
my one word is believe and I believe in
you I want to see that amazing thing
that's inside here come out and explode
into the world so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you today we're going to
learn from a man who went from being a
non-native foreign in Singapore and
being the son of a maritime worker and
dentist to becoming the first house
music producer to perform at the
Olympics and closing in on 100 billion
views on his music videos he's cago and
here's my take on his top ten rules of
success enjoy
so kicking us off rule number one is do
your own thing I try not to care what
other people think if you're always
trying to listen to everyone else
you'll never make something unique it'll
blend in too much it'll be too Janette
try to find things arrest Annette my
kind of style or resonate with my
economies sometimes I redo my work 20
times before I'm satisfied and I love it
other people might say yeah it's so now
that's it after the fourth or fifth time
but I keep going
I guess it's my thing running away at
the details see to something that can be
added or stripped away just to make it
more edgy or to make something no one's
experienced before
being artists you too often expected to
expose yourself to show who you are and
not what you do I don't care much for
that
I admire people who focus on doing the
wrong thing
expressing themselves in the wrong way
if people love what I do if they love
the actual finished product whether its
design or music and that's what matters
that's my job my expression my thing
was yours
this is a solid opening I love how he's
telling his story and is actually a
theme to it and music and people don't
usually tell their story so well so this
is a fantastic start and I also agree
with doing your own thing it's
understanding having this up earnest to
know what you stand for what your one
word is who you want to be and then
going out and living it when you are
living somebody else's life you will
never be successful you've got to figure
out what that thing is for you and go
all-in on it so it's a great start to
the video let's move on to rule number
two just start was this always like the
end goal to be like the billion streams
and Spotify like when you first started
out was it more of a hobby was it did
you see this going in as a career for
you well in the beginning I was just
making music for fun it was a hobby and
I actually started studying business and
finance and government so I was studying
and I was just like having like music as
a hobby even though it was my dream I
thought it was like it was impossible to
break through so many people do exactly
what I was doing yeah so I was yeah I
started studying and and then suddenly
like yeah my music started getting
attention online and that was like when
I really started thinking okay this is
this is something yeah I have an
opportunity right now this is something
that you see over and over and over and
over and over again you start doing
something because you love it because
you have the passion and you don't know
how that's ever gonna work out and you
may think it may never work out your
brain is telling you down another
workout but your heart is telling you
got to keep doing it big decisions with
the heart little ones with the head you
don't need to have a fully fleshed-out
plan because your plan is gonna change
anyway you just need to start let's move
on the rule number three create
something you're proud of every time I
release something there's a lot of
people
that has expectations to that I whole
like that they want the track to be good
and there's definitely a limit of
pressure but I don't think it really
affects me that much what I make music
and then I make music because I love
making music and I don't really think
about like I hope people are gonna like
it obviously but almost they think that
I want to make something that I'm proud
of and then something that's yeah that's
something I can yeah be proud of it's
the best song that I I can hopefully
like yeah
so the test I like to use is do I want
to show this to my grandkids I want to
make something that I'm so proud of I
want my grandkids to see it this video I
want my grandkids to see it and if you
take that importance into everything you
do every speech every video every post
on social media every product every
every service every day showing up that
you want to tell your grandkids a story
but what happened today you going with
that importance every single day you
will make amazing things happen let's go
to rule number four don't limit yourself
I think people were just hearing the
same stuff and you know there's a point
where like you know progressive house or
whatever you want to call it like you
know 128bpm like you know a couple years
ago that was the new hot thing that was
what everyone want to hear you know they
want to go and dance really fast or
whatever it is they want to go to a
party and now it's like either there's
been so much of it tygo was now home
with a new genre I guess maybe it was
because it's like there's no trumpet
like there's no beaches and like the
summer is pretty short of no way so
maybe I was just like I was sitting in
my room dreaming about so I'm dreaming
about beaches and dreaming maybe that
was the reason why I started making that
music I made today
do you like the label tropical house is
that appropriate er yeah I guess I guess
it makes sense cuz it's like it's music
that fits for the summer but I don't
really like and I don't really classify
my own try something like cuz I doubt it
I kind of like just look at it as music
I don't want to like put myself into one
genre I love this rule so far it's my
favorite rule number four or stepping up
kygo as soon as you accept that label
then you start creating only within that
label and it's hard to break out and do
more and more things and as soon as you
box yourself in then the
less and less happy that you get as you
continue doing that same thing over and
over and over again so other people may
label you other people may put you in a
certain kind of box but don't limit
yourself don't accept that label
yourself continue to be limitless let's
go to rule number 5 be inspired by
everything I'm just like inspired by
everything when I listened to I listened
to a lot of music and I'm just inspired
by every style of music and Ed Sheeran
and passenger and all those guises I get
in spite of everything in a lot of like
electronic music this is Swedish guy
called Oliver Nelson yeah he's kind of
unknown but he was one of my main
inspirations when I started making this
style of music so it's just it's just
music they say in general I get inspired
by other artists and other music I love
the message of finding inspiration
everything reminds of the guy behind me
on the wall Howard Schultz started
Starbucks went to Italy on vacation saw
how Italians all hung around our coffee
shop and he wanted to bring that idea to
North America and that created Starbucks
and so there's always inspiration out
there whether you're on vacation whether
you're in staying in line at the
Department of Motor Vehicles with here
at a grocery store there's always
something that you can pull from and if
you ever find yourself bored or
uninspired just look around you and say
how can I be creatively inspired by
something here in my current environment
and learn from that and apply it to your
life or to your business moving on rule
number six collaborate definitely helps
to get new inputs from other people so
every time I go in a studio you learn
something every time and go into the
studio with another artist
so it definitely helps you out to work
with other people because you get their
inputs and their ideas and maybe they
have some new melodies and there's some
kind of variations that I haven't
thought of and so it definitely it
definitely helps you to get input from
other people I feel like just like I'm
I'm always kind of growing and evolving
as an artist and and yeah every time I
work with someone I learned something
it's it's I can like put my finger on
like what it is but I learned like new
variations and that you can go from that
chord off to this court and oh that
sounds cool and it's so it's just
something new that I take from every
collaboration and every track I'm making
or it's it's a new sound that I found in
my in the software you think that I
really like so I kind of saved that
sound and I use it for a later song so
it's yeah it's just like you kind of
like constantly just like growing and
evolving and and learn new things
there's a real danger in doing the same
thing over and over and over again being
around the same people the same
customers the same environment you just
stay stagnant and as entrepreneurs we
hate that we need growth and so exposing
yourself to new ideas to people who
bring a different vibe a different
flavor whether it's a one-off thing or
whether it's a ongoing relationship
where they become a business partner or
a piece of your company it's really
really really really important because
you can get by for a year or two just
doing the same thing but eventually you
are going to phase out you're gonna fade
you're gonna lose your your will you're
gonna lose your happiness because you
need to inject that variety in and
collaboration is a fantastic way to do
it let's move on to rule number seven
work hard
I love the mistake a lot
I've been Miami brother nice to death
row since today as today I wanna become
money I'm also been icon she loved music
because any teeth you don't travel
harvester this different car so sit
there sit against except what they're
there for the your belief and I'm
nothing
I think there's a knock against young
people odd or Millennials a lot that we
don't like to work hard I can say we
because I'm the first year 1980 of
Millennials we like to work hard we just
have to find something that we love
doing and this is a message that will
come over it again them again and again
like the most successful people in the
world you've got to work hard you've got
to find the thing that you love so much
that you can work until 6:00 in the
morning doing that you just lose track
of time doing because it feels you up
find that thing and even if it doesn't
make sense on how to continue
practically doing it you have to keep
going eventually we'll work out let's
move to rule number eight model success
I started taking piano lesson this one
house like success old it was my mom
it's good that I guess I get a beginning
I didn't like really enjoyed it I was
like I just did it because my mom wanted
me to do it after a couple years when I
like started learning some songs I
started really getting into it I just
composed melodious on a piano and then I
did that for a couple years and then I
heard about Avicii in 2009 and before
that I wasn't really into electronic
music I listened to some songs but it
wasn't I listened more she liked the
band Coldplay try to chill peppers and
The Killers and stuff like that
but then I got really inspired by VG and
and his style of music so I bought logic
studio and I bought like a MIDI keyboard
and just like learn myself I produce if
someone who looks like you has gone on
to accomplish something amazing then you
can too and I think surround yourself in
an environment where that is always
hitting you or you look up the people
and you read their biographies or you
watch the interviews and you consume
yourself constantly with their success
that can be motivating for you to break
out of your current environment to go
off and do something amazing yourself
I'm a big believer in model success it's
why I started this channel and hopefully
take that message to heart let's move on
the rule number
find your creative zone when you like in
and out of hotels and in and out of
planes it's it's hard to get in that and
the creative zone so I usually make
music when I'm back home and what is it
about the surround surrounded they meet
that kind of quiet and then it
definitely helps yeah yeah have some a
long time and be able to just be in yeah
and um my hometown and just hang out
with some friends and and it kind of
gets me that that yeah I creative so and
then I get motivated and inspired to me
to make music I think knowing how you
tick and be able to create that
environment that allows you to succeed
is super super important one quick
example for me I hate fluorescent lights
fluorescent lights give me a headache
they flicker it's really hard for me to
focus when they're on and so I need not
lots of natural light I like having a
window in front of me when I'm working
it allows you to be the most productive
and so that's an easy hack right if you
understand the environment that will
allow you to come out and be your best
self and create the best work then go
and build it you're an entrepreneur you
get to control the situation take charge
alright last rule number 10 have fun get
out of bed early in the morning no I'm
not a morning person not waking up one
today I woke up like 12:30 yeah I didn't
go to bed until like 4:00 no so it's
like kind of like that's that's the
sleeping pattern I have I would like to
know if kygo sounds as kygo okay without
kygo sounds
all right thank you guys so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed I'd love to
know which rule was the most valuable to
you that you're going to immediately
apply somehow to your life or to your
business rule number four was my
personal favorite let me know yours in
the comments down below now I made this
video because the song Smith asked me to
so if there's someone you'd like me to
cover in a future top ten video go check
out the link in the description and you
can go and cast your vote I also want to
give a quick Charlotte to Cleese stuff
Logies thank you so much for picking up
a copy my book you're one word and
posting the link to it on Instagram and
the picture I really really appreciate
it man and I'm so glad you enjoyed the
book so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you soon
let me give you one one season was one
long way down the most important work
ever if you had to think of one word
that's most important to you that sums
you Apple that would be like a little
beacon pay believe nation if you want to
know what the most important one word is
for Tony Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah
Winfrey will.i.am and Howard Schultz I
have a very special secret video for you
check the description for details